America's Next Topmodel alum Lisa Marie  D'Amato gives birth and streams it all  live on Facebook Lisa and her husband  Adam Friedman who appeared on marriage  boot camp  welcome to their second son Venice eye  on Thursday and the entire experience is  documented in the video you see the live  birth from Lisa's point of view until  the doctor puts the little cutie on the  chest come see me oh hello surrounded by  her family and close friends lisa says  baby venice came after 14 hours and fans  seemed excited to take part in the  experience with her one viewer wrote  amazing experience thanks so much for  sharing Congrats to the happy couple  you